so good we think we know what entropy is
the number of ways you can rearrange a
system
we think it makes sense that entropy
increases over time
what we're left to do is understand what
this has to do
with our experience of time in the
everyday world
how does that help explain this
asymmetry we have about the past versus
the future
this feeling that we have that we're
flowing through time
well let's just take one example here's
my favorite example of an asymmetry
this is an asymmetry of prediction
versus records you're walking down the
street
you look down the sidewalk you see a
broken egg can we ask ourselves because
we're in a philosophical mood
what is the future of that egg likely to
hold
you don't know right there's many
different possible things that could
happen to the egg you could just sit
there
it could be cleaned up by somebody there
could be a rainstorm washing it away
there's many possible futures open but
if you asked yourself
what does the past of that egg probably
involve
with very high confidence you will
believe that there used to be
an unbroken egg and it got dropped and
it broke
so right away just seeing this thing in
the world right now this artifact
broken egg on the sidewalk you infer a
difference
between the past history of that egg and
the future history of that egg
why well it's not because of the
fundamental laws of physics
given the configuration today egg on the
ground messy
etc there are many many arrangements of
the individual molecules that could
account for that
and accordingly there are many many
possible futures as we said many things
could happen
to the egg if all you knew
were the fundamental laws of physics
there is a precisely
equal number of past things that the egg
could have gone through
the conservation of information
convinces us that the number of past
possible histories of that egg is
exactly equal
to the number of future possible
histories of that egg
but there is one big difference that we
know the universe started with a big
bang
and that big bang had a very low entropy
this is what
philosophers call the past hypothesis of
low entropy in the universe
so we know two things we know the
current state of the egg
and we know the initial condition that
we started with very low entropy
we that's where the imbalance comes from
that's where we know a little bit
something more about the past than about
the future and we can use that
information
to say given the existence of a broken
egg on the sidewalk
today and the existence of a very very
low
entropy big bang we can infer that there
used to be
an unbroken egg as you go through your
life as you are remembering things and
predicting things about the future you
are constantly relying on the fact
that the entropy of the universe was
very low near the big bang
you might not have known that you are
relying on that fact but it's crucially
important to how we live our lives